(Risas)
Es cierto.
Lo que comprendo ahora
es que su regalo de USD 1000 es probablemente un regalo de bienvenida.
Y debería pensar formas para que colaboren con nosotros
e inviertan de forma más significativa.
Sé que esto suena un poco mercenario.
No estoy confundida sobre cómo suena.
Pero aquí está lo que les quiero contar,
porque esto es parte de lo que todos mis clientes quieren evitar,
porque piensan que es la pelusa y que no es importante.
Si no comprenden por qué se preocupan y qué valoran
¿cómo podrán contarles sobre su trabajo?
Quiero que financien nuestro trabajo, lo quiero.
Pero también quiero que tengan una experiencia significativa como donantes,
que así se sientan como si fuéramos socios
y no como un cajero automático, ¿no?
Así que es importante hacer preguntas,
porque cuánto más sepan de ellos
y sepan qué valoran,
más pueden encauzar la conversación
en una dirección sobre trabajo que resonará con ellos.
Y una vez que superen la parte de la presentación
y pasen a cosas divertidas
como: "¿Por qué es filántropo?"
¿Cierto?
"¿Por qué invierte en nuevas ideas?
¿Quiere que retribuir sea un valor que pasará a sus hijos?
¿Podemos ayudarle con eso?"
Es muy asombroso, muy significativo
y recuerden, es una conversación,
no es un interrogatorio,
no es una entrevista.
No entren allí y les cuenten todo lo que ya saben sobre ellos,
porque investigaron.
No obtienen puntos extra por saber usar Google.
Ellos hablan un 75 %, Uds. escuchan.
Uds. hablan un 25 %.
Es mejor ser un mejor oyente que un buen showman.
Y una vez que comprendan qué les preocupa,
pueden hablar con ellos sobre qué les preocupa.
Puede contarles sobre Uds.
Ahora, cuando hagan eso,
no profundicen mucho en los trapos sucios o los perderán.
Se parece mucho a cuando me siento con los chicos de finanzas
y digo,
ya saben: "¿Cómo va el trabajo?"
Estoy buscando algo como un pulgar arriba, pulgar abajo.
Pero lo que obtengo a veces
es una larga descripción de las tendencias de los mercados.
y mi cerebro abandona mi cuerpo
y empiezo a pensar a qué hora cierra la tintorería.
(Risas)
Como que no tengo la capacidad para eso.
Y no tienen ese nivel de detalle en nuestro trabajo.
Si quieren, ellos le harán las preguntas.
Esto es algo que ocurre una y otra vez,
porque... aquí va un ejemplo.
Trabajé con este CEO una vez
y me contrataron para enseñarle a hablar con seres humanos,
como un ser humano.
(Risas)
Era un trabajo muy difícil.
Seguía teniendo buenos encuentros con donantes
y no cerraba ninguna donación.
Y no podía entender cuál era el problema,
así que al final, dijo: "Voy a ir contigo"
Así que fui con él a encuentros y lo que pasaba era
que entraba en tan nivel de detalle con los donantes
que sus ojos estaban vidriosos,
y entonces tras acabar con su discurso de 15 minutos,
ellos literalmente decían,
esto pasó como tres veces consecutivas,
"Dios, eso suena bien. Felicidades.
Sigan con su buen trabajo".
Y eso fue el encuentro,
que obviamente no era el resultado que buscábamos.
Él no podía entender lo que trataba de decirle,
y finalmente, en un acto de pura desesperación, decía...
"¿Sabes lo que me encanta?
La NASA.
Me encanta la NASA.
Creo que es increíblemente asombroso que hayamos descubierto
cómo llevar a una persona a la luna.
Pienso que es increíble.
Pienso que la idea de llevar a alguien a la luna,
y ellos andando en la luna,
y me encantan los cohetes espaciales.
Me encantan los cohetes espaciales, los cohetes son increíbles.
Pero si empiezas a hablarme sobre el cohete,
y cómo llega a la luna,
y las matemáticas y ecuaciones científicas,
y cómo el cohete llega a la luna,
te prometo que me ahorcaré con mi propio cabello".
(Risas)
Decía "Así no es cómo le cuentas a la gente sobre tu trabajo.
¿Cuál es la necesidad?"
¿Cuál es la idea, cierto?
¿Cómo abordas la necesidad,
por qué eres mejor que cualquier otro?
¿Y qué puedes hacer para lograrlo?
¿Cómo pueden ayudar a llegar a la luna?
Eso es lo bueno.
Si pueden hacerlo, puede que estén listos para hacer la pregunta.
Ahora, no espero
a todos súper emocionados por pedir dinero a la gente.
Por eso el desarrollo es una profesión real
y no un pasatiempo incómodo.
(Risas)
Los buenos recaudadores naturales aman a la gente,
pueden y hablarán con cualquiera,
encontrarán puntos en común con cualquiera,
son tus amigos que hablan con la gente en el ascensor
o en la tienda.
Creen en el trabajo que requiere
tanto construir relaciones como mantenerlas.
Y naturalmente tienen una alta tolerancia al rechazo.
Pero no espero que todos sean innatos,
y no tiene que ser innato recaudar dinero.
Solo tienen que respetar a la gente y el proceso
y hacer el trabajo.
¿Cómo se reconciliarán con su equipaje?
¿Cómo conseguirán construir relaciones?
Si lo hacen, estarán listos para hacer la pregunta.
Y la pregunta es a veces tan simple como usar la frase:
"¿Lo consideraría?
¿Consideraría convertirse en un donante mensual?
¿Consideraría incrementar su apoyo a 100 dólares?
¿Consideraría invertir en nuestro trabajo a un nivel del millón de dólares?
"Consideraría" hace un par de cosas increíbles.
Uno, da al donante una salida fácil.
Puede decir "no", sin que sea un "sí-no".
Y segundo, les da una segunda pregunta:
"Bien, ¿qué consideraría?"
(Risas)
Es bueno, ¿verdad?
Cuando hagan eso, recuerden, no están pidiendo para Uds.
Piden en nombre de todas las personas a las que sirven
o son tocadas por su genio.
No es un favor personal, ¿cierto?
Siéntanse orgullosos de la pregunta, es increíble que hagan este trabajo.
No traten de ser quienes no son,
van a estas reuniones y piensan que necesitan darse un gran impulso.
Sean Uds., la autenticidad importa, nadie quiere un impostor.
Solo sean Uds. mismos.
Y por favor,
por favor, no torpedeen su propia pregunta.
Con esto me refiero a que
no entren en una reunión y digan: "Tuve un ED que hacía esto todo el rato,
dejé de invitarle.
Decía: "No estamos aquí para pedirles dinero".
(Risas)
¡Sí, lo estamos!
Eso es exactamente, literalmente, por lo que estamos aquí hoy.
No hagan eso.
No digan: "Lo que pueda hacer para ayudar".
Es sin duda la forma más rápida de conseguir la donación más pequeña
de alguien que puede darle y salirse con la suya.
No bromeo.
Y manténganse.
Una vez que hagan la pregunta:
"¿Consideraría apoyarnos a un nivel de 10 000 dólares?
¿O de cinco? ¿O de dos? ¿O de uno?
¿Sabe qué? Tómese el año.
¡Es el mejor, gracias!"
¡No hagan eso".
Hagan la pregunta,
esperen hasta 10, cuenten 10 antes de hablar de nuevo,
mantengan su cara así.
(Risas)
Son adultos.
Tienen todo el poder en esta situación.
Pueden responder la pregunta.
No la retiren.
Lo que me lleva a mi favorito.
No hay preguntas, no hay donaciones.
Si no hacen una pregunta real
nadie les dará dinero real.
Y si no le dan dinero real,
no podrán hacer nada con esto.
Es muy simple: sin preguntas no hay donaciones.
Escuchen, amaría vivir en un mundo
donde no tuviéramos que pedir a la gente dinero
para hacer trabajo importante que cambiará las vidas de la gente.
Amaría no tener que enseñar a la gente
a defender la importancia de la alimentación y la vivienda
y educar a las personas.
Pero en este mundo en que vivimos,
y si estamos comprometidos a hacer este trabajo,
y hacerlo bien,
tenemos que estar tan comprometidos con el arte de financiar este trabajo
como lo estamos con el arte de ejecutarlo.
Voy a repetir eso, porque creo que es algo importante.
Tenemos que estar tan comprometidos con el arte de financiar nuestro trabajo
como con el arte de realizarlo.
Y, en esencia,
el arte de financiar el trabajo significa que debemos creer realmente
que el propósito y el privilegio de nuestro trabajo
es proporcionar a las personas
una forma extraordinaria de usar su riqueza
que cambiará las vidas de la gente.
Es una oportunidad,
porque en esencia, eso es lo que es.
¿Y cuán grande es eso?
Gracias.
(Aplausos) (Vítores)